It says here, "Erica Kirk's parents are Kent and Mellani France
or France." Kent France was a prominent figure in the defense
industry. >> You know, the thing about Erica Kirk is I
100% believe that that's an arranged
>> Chairman of Rathon's Israel division,
>> by the Sweden. But we go a little bit >> Technically,
her grandfather was a Viking. And what did Cash Patel say when
Charlie Kirk passed away? We'll see you in Valhalla, brother.
Eight.
>> Nick Fuentes believes that Charlie Kirk and Erica Kirk
were in arranged marriage and they met at Bohemian Grove.
Nick also has more questions about Erica about how quickly she
took over CPSA. More I don't buy any of the Israel conspiracies,
but this I'm interested in. Okay. With $20 donation. Hey Nick,
wondering what you know know slth think about the Romanian angels
along with Erica's possible past connection to Trump via Miss
Arizona. Yeah, Miss Arizona. The timing with blocking the file
release of the Epstein files, Kirk's death and WWE style funeral
is bizarre. Talk about honeypot. Have you ever seen the movie
Hostel? If you know, you know that's a lot of schizophrenia in
one one $20 donation. Jesus. >> Um, you know the thing
about Erica Kirk is I 100% believe that that's an arranged marriage.
Charlie and Erica, I do not believe for one second
that they met organically.
How do you think they met each other? Do you think that they
bumped into each other at CPAC and Charlie said, "Hey, let's
go on a date."
No, they were set up together by somebody who set them up. Hey,
I will say
I'd heard they met on a flight to Israel. Someone I think Candace
or somebody said they met on a flight to Israel. Oh, cuz I'm
supposed to believe Candace.
>> Well, Nick's supposed to believe that they were set
up by the Israeli government. Okay, that's like his thing for
the past 10 years. How is he going to just drop that one? Anyway,
we
>> Charlie, I'm sure, is he's super ambitious, super powerful,
running this organization. They told him, "You need a wife."
I'm sure he wants a wife. They told him you need a wife. If you
want to run for office, you need a wife and kids. You need a
family. They're grooming him to be super powerful.
So, he's hanging out at Bohemian Grove and they say, "We need
to give you a wife. Uh, we know somebody. We know this girl."
And she's in she's in some How do they know her? Who set them
up? And where did this girl come from that's going to be Charlie
Kurt's wife and bear his children?
I think that was an arranged marriage.
And that tells me that she is tapped into some kind of network
in some way. I don't know how. People talk about she was a pageant
girl.
Nick is seething because he didn't get his deep state wife. You're
just wrong. He got his deep state wife. He rejected his deep
state wife because he's deeply deeply closeted and then she went
on and married somebody else and moved to Israel. Okay. >> Well,
and she ran this charity. I maybe there's a connection there.
I would not be surprised at all
that if you're talking about Erica Kirk that I believe
people say Israel Charlie Kirk. Yeah, I don't know about that
one. Let's look at the marriage. Erica Kirk is now taking over
Turning Point. That's suspicious as because what we are being
led to believe is that Erica Kirk is the archetypal trad. Isn't
that the perception they're
when you look at some of these Oh, Erica said she saw Charlie
in Israel. They didn't know each other at the time. And then
Kane says Charlie Kirk was interviewing Erica and ended the interview
with a date proposal. clips. She's supposed to be the ultimate
trad wife. She's speaking at the Young Women's Leadership Summit.
She's on podcast saying, "Oh my gosh, I can't focus cuz I'm so
in love with Charlie. If he's here, I can't focus." Oh, hold
on. Uh, what do we got? 750.
550. That's 13 plus 53. We're a sub and $2 away. Okay, guys.
A sub and $2 away from two more hours on the stream. >> Let's
go. Chicken sandwich is almost >> One sub, two sub. We
can get through that to that 60 bucks. We can make it. All right.
I believe in you guys. Donate, donate, donate. Put more time
in the stream cuz I'm so smitten.
Like that's the character that she's playing. That's the character
that they're selling us. Her husband gets shot in the neck. >> Yeah.
Hold on. I do believe that they're putting on something because
I saw the one part, the one clip where she was on Charlie's show
with him and she sits there. She looks like she's got him by
the balls, but she's like across the room and she's like, "I
love you. You're my best friend.
That felt like the fakest, most threatening, you're my best friend
I'd ever seen." Can you find the clip? >> Uh, I will look
for it. Yeah, >> got to find the clip. Also, uh, when I
was asking for donations, she was only 17. Says, "What if I'm
broke and homeless? Get a job.
Get a [__] job." Okay. Can you go find the Bad Bunny
rant about how you shouldn't be here watching this if you can't
pay five bucks?
Okay.
Come on, man. Come on, man. >> Wait. Stop. That is a poor
person who wants to be humiliated. >> Okay, wait. What
is this? Hold on. Wait. So, let's get this straight. 13 years
ago, Erica Kirk did a music video that has 1.7 million views
on YouTube. In the video, she zip lines right past the time stamp
910. When was Charlie shot? Oh, yeah. September 10th. She goes
in the comments of the video to thank Tyler Robert, son of the
lead singer, for having so much fun shooting the video. She zip
lines down Fremont Street. The meaning of Fremont is derived
from the French and Germanic roots combining elements that lead
us to meanings such as noble protector, protector of freedom,
or freedom mountain.
What shirt what shirt was Charlie wearing? Oh yeah, that's right.
Freedom. We being trolled.
But nothing gets past Anons. Good job, friends. 07. If you missed
the snake eyes dig we did on Thursday, I'll post the link below.
Wait, what?
How long is this on the back of a
>> Jesus? Uh, simply substance. Thank you for your gifted
sub to McBoots.
>> Wait, does she actually have a [__] stamp?
That's Is that Is that a temporary tattoo? She can't be a trad
wife with a [__] stamp, dude. What are you doing?
>> I let her lie by the wide
for getting at the county fair. My babies, my kind of >> That
wasn't even her. That was definitely her. What? Oh, like walking
from behind. That's not her. Yeah, sure. Oh, that's definitely
her ass. Yeah, I wouldn't know.
sure, sure, sure, sure. >> Why would they stunt double?
>> Wait, I don't know. Hold on. I actually have to ask
a question.
>> Uh, division five player with two months. Is that on
Wait, that must be on Twitch. Thank you for the primer. Whatever
that was. Division five player. Thank you very much. Appreciate
it. I'll add the two hours and then Sher's got the clip for us.
Let's check out the clip. Where's the clip? Let's check out the
clip. There's the clip. My wife >> Okay. Warning to the
left. Erica Ch.
>> I've read the ch from Charlie. Okay. >> I have
dyslexia. I have dyslexia. Erica Kirk makes Charlie Kirk look
like a moderate. He even admitted it by far. I'm not even close.
I'm a moderate compared to Erica. Buckle up. You guys woke up
a beast. >> Joins us. Erica Kirk, the beautiful legendary
Erica. >> I love you so much. >> I love you. >> You're
my best friend. >> Welcome to the Charlie Kirk show. We
have asked the legendary
>> that's threatening to me. >> The legendary
legendary Erica Kirk. >> Why do you just randomly You're
my best friend. Thank you. Like why?
>> I love you so much. >> I would never lie to you.
>> Welcome to the Charlie Kirk show. We have asked friend.
You're my best friend. I can kill myself before I >> the
audience for questions you >> saying anything like that.
>> pick one. >> Who is more conservative and why?
>> by far. Not even close. I am a moderate compared to
Erica. >> Andrew always jokes that once you got married
to me, you got more based. >> That's true. That is true.
No, Erica is very conservative. Do Do you think having kids made
you more conservative?
>> Which I didn't think was possible. 100 P >> but
100% >> which she didn't think was possible. So what does
that even mean?
>> did he used to be more human before he married her?
>> I have no idea. I Dude, I don't know. It feels like
very forced, but whatever. Maybe they were just really happy.
I don't know. >> No, they weren't. >> I don't know,
man. I don't know. I'm being told 2:30 in the music video. Rolling
down the back rows, hanging at the window, riding with her hair
in the wind, in her hands in the sky like she's
She's my kind of ponytail. Pretty sounds like the country looks
like the city. I march along to whatever
time she plays.
She's my kind.
>> Wait, why did you want me to go to the zipline bed?
>> She's my kind of Sunday driving rolling down the back
row hanging at the window
with her hair in the wind and her hands in the sky
like she's fly.
>> Oh, I see. 9 10 10. >> Got it. Got it. Got it.
Okay,
dude. I
these conspiracies are getting a little too contrived. Okay,
we need to reel it back in. We need to We need to get reeled
in again. Wild >> graphically in front of everybody. Shouldn't
Miss Trad shouldn't she be like despondent? And I'm not trying
to judge how people grieve. It's not >> No, you're literally
judging how she grieavves. You're literally Shouldn't she be
grieving more? Shouldn't she be totally destroyed? I'm not trying
to criticize how she's grieving. No, that's
>> That's 100% what you just did. Me personally, if someone
assassinated you in front of me, I'd be wearing black every day
with like a lace veil, like a big hat, big black hat with a black
lace >> for maybe like 3 months. >> You're like my
best friend and you.
>> Okay. All right. >> Our position to judge how
they grieve or what their response is. Maybe she's just got unbelievable
resolve. But if she really is the ultimate trad wife who knows
her place and is a helper to her husband, a helpmate, and she's
so smitten with him and she's the perfect
to us for years, then when her husband gets shot in the neck
and blood starts burning everywhere in front of everybody who
starts screaming and running away, shouldn't she be like in shock?
Shouldn't she be like in a catatonic state or crying and be a
be in a veil as a widow somewhere? Oh,
I did not pre-watch.
All right. >> I just know I know what the like the iconic
imagery of a widow is. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> It's very
Beetlejuice.
>> Okay. That's one way. Sure. You just like the aesthetics.
You weren't commenting on the widow party. You were just like,
I just feel like it would be cool to do this. Be like my form
of a celebration. Uh, Nick, I'm going I have that video in my
docket literally beside some of the other Erica Erica Kirk conspiracy
stuff. So, we're >> But that's not what we got at all.
She start the second he dies, she takes over Turning Point. That
happened like two days later. She's all of a sudden the president
of this $500 million
super influential, now super powerful after Charlie became a
martyr. And she's given speeches.
She's given a speech. And the speech I'm just I'm sorry it's
totally canned. The first speech she gave next to his empty chair.
She's like doing this weird a effect wiping away tears that aren't
there with this scripted speech. You know, >> oh private
hop, thank you for the gifted
>> That's so rich. That is so rich coming from Fuentes
where you sit here talking about like
trad anything and the desire for it just isn't there. >> Listen,
he knows he wants his trad
wife.
>> Wife in quotes. He wants it. He wants it >> The
battle cry of this widow. the cries of this widow will echo like
a and then at the WWE memorial she comes out to
and she does this like she's Mary in her white suit
her white suit her makeup her >> call her Hillary Clinton
call her Hillary Clinton in the pants suit >> and she goes
out with fireworks at her husband's funeral like this she posed
you see that and then she goes up and says yeah I'm running.
>> Remember we were talking about that sthing hatred for
women that all gay men share, you know, >> turning point
now and this is how it's giving me like Claire Underwood vibes.
>> I think that was an arranged marriage and either she
was like a handler or she
she had political ambitions of her own. But yeah, I don't know.
Look, who is Erica Kirk now? This is a person that is being foisted
on us.
And look, don't get me wrong. You lost your husband.
I am deeply sorry for you. I really am. I'm praying for you.
I am deeply sorry for you. I can't imagine what you're going
through. But you becoming president of Turning Point and now
being forced upon us. That's an allgether different story.
You know, it's like I said on Monday, and Alex Jones didn't like
this. He said it was mean. A lot of people didn't like it. You
want our sympathy, you got it. You want our prayers? You got
it. People would, you know, walk over broken glass for this widow
who can who can even sympathize, who can even understand what
she's going through right now. But, okay, get to the meme part.
>> They're asking us to accept her as like this new leader.
They're foisting her on us as a political leader, and that I
don't like. >> I'm sorry, dude. This pose is likeing her
on us as a political leader. And that I'm sorry. And that and
that I do not like. Okay. That is unacceptable.
That's just a >> that I don't. >> It's just a little
He's got a lot of zest going on. Okay. >> at any given
moment in time. >> I don't like love it, by the way. Love
the presentation. Okay. No, no actual critiques. Okay. The guy
is a fantastic showman. the Greatest Showman perhaps >> that
because that's manipulative.
That is predatory
of She's the widow. Who can criticize her? She's a widow. Who
could ever say anything negative about her? They're exploiting
that. They're exploiting that. She's untouchable. She's beyond
>> Dude, the Groper musical in like 10 years going to go
so hard. The Groper musical romanticizing the feud between Charlie
Kirk and Nick Fentes. That's going to be nuts. coach. She's the
victim of the tragedy. It's like it's like um when a victim of
a school shooting starts running an anti-gun nonprofit, you know,
it's like March for Our Lives. Cuz who could He's calling He's
calling Erica Kirk David Hog. Is there any bigger
what would you call it? Like antichrist to the conservative movement
than is it? Is it David Hog? It's David Hog, right?
guy who's at uh what was it Parkland who started like a nonprofit
and does all the appearances in media >> criticize a kid
that almost got killed in a school shooting.
You know,
it's giving me vibes. I don't like that. I don't like when some
victim of some atrocity is then presented as a political figure
because it's like, okay, who the are you? You're the victim of
some tragedy. That sound Okay, give me a second here, guys. I'm
going to go uh I'm going to go I'm going to hit play on this.
I'm still listening. I have to find some Advil. My eyes are like,
you ever get that like pressure headache behind your eyes? I
need like two Advil. I'll be right back. >> Sounds like
a really thing to say. But it's like, how do I know you're not
being controlled by somebody? Because quite honestly, we knew
who Charlie Kirk was and he built the organization. We have no
idea who you are. What makes you qualified to run Turning Point
because your husband got What makes you qualified? We don't know
anything about you. We don't know where you came from. We don't
know anything about you. For all we know, you are working for
some other person or now the board is going to run it. >> Now
some shadowy force is going to run turning point through you
or you represent. We don't know. We don't know who you are.
>> But no one can say that cuz she's a widow and that I
don't like because this is a high-profile king. It is >> forcing
people to ask a lot of questions and this is the one aspect of
it that we're not allowed to ask questions about because
it's in bad taste. Well, you know what? This is politics. >> Oh,
what the [__] Oops. We're back. >> If you want
to speak at the funeral, no one's going to question that. But
you seize control of the organization right away. I'm seizing
the reigns and no one dare question me because I'm a widow. >> I'm
sorry. You think TPUSA is like the
>> Why is this a
What transparency do you need with them? >> I think I don't
know if it's about transparency. I think he's concerned. It's
like an an organization with a ton of influence that was very
invested behind Charlie Kirk and being able to sit in the seat
Charlie Kirk did would be extremely valuable. You could enrich
yourself. You could really control like have a a strong say in
American politics, right? >> Yeah. So, I'm going to need
Nick Fuentes instead of just saying who can't take that seat,
who should >> Who who did Erica take that seat from that
you thought that person should have it? And don't say yourself.
>> No, because it couldn't have ever been him. And I don't
think that I don't think anybody he likes could have been
>> Yeah. So, it's like that. I don't like that one bit.
And um and it doesn't really track. Like I said, the if you watch
any of the clips, it's just like downright insulting the way
that she's presented as like a trad wife. And correct me if I'm
wrong, and I might be, but if you're the ultimate trad, shouldn't
you be a little bit more torn up about this? I know I sound like
an [__] Where's the tears? Really, >> dude?
Really? >> I hate men.
>> I hate men. The mascara is waterproof today. Today,
you get eyeliner that is waterproof. You can literally set your
face. Rain could not make your makeup >> You're a trad
wife. You're a You're a helpmate. You're smitten. You're so in
love. Blah blah blah. Your husband got publicly executed in front
of all of his adoring fans 3 days ago. You're giving a speech
today, taking control of Turning Point, vowing like that we're
going to make Turning Point bigger than ever.
Is that typical Tradife behavior? Who is this person exactly?
Who is this? No one knows.
So, I'm Listen, and I know I don't really buy a lot of the Israel
conspiracies.
That is something I'm very interested in. Eric Kirk is someone
I'm very interested in.
Okay. He's given a little nod kind of in the same way Candace
is to being like maybe Eric Kirk maybe Eric Kirk wanted control
of Turning Point and did this. I feel like he's given nods to
it and it's just like bro at least Israel's like kind of evil.
I don't know what Erica Kirk is. Like at least Israel is doing
a genocide man. Well, I'm sorry, but
according to rumors, conspiracies, she might be a sex trafficker
>> uh involved with like an organization who is organ trafficker
actually.
>> organ trafficking organization she was tied to in Romania.
I don't know what that is. I don't know. Is she a Mormon? Is
Erica Kirk wasn't a Mormon, right? She must be evangelical Christian
if she's married to Charlie Kirk, right? >> Has to be.
>> Yeah, it has to be. Okay. Cuz it's some it's some Christian
organization. They would be tearing her to shreds right now if
she was a Mormon. >> Sure, sure, sure. Cuz I was just thinking
like why would she be in Romania running like working with some
charity as a Christian? It just see I feel like Mormons are the
people who do the missions, right?
>> Uh no Christians. >> No, Mormons go on Mormons
are like required to go on a mission. >> Oh, okay. >> When
they turn like 18 or something >> as a part of that church.
I understand missionaries and missions are both. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. You know, uh, when people talk about energy
weapons and decoy shooters and trap doors, you lose me. He knows
about the trapoor. Let's go.
Trapoor theory is the best theory. Projector theory kind of sucks,
but when you talk about the person that succeeds Charlie Kirk,
that's relevant.
Who's going to take his place? Good question. It's the wife.
Who's the wife? No one knows. So, you know, some of that stuff,
um, you know, the Epstein files, I don't know how much that plays
into it because Charlie was in favor of covering them up.
A week after the DOJ covered up the Epstein files, Charlie Kirk
went on his show and said, "I trust the government. I don't want
to ask any more questions about it." So, I don't think that had
anything to do with it.
I think they just took advantage of it. But, yeah, but the the
wife is sort of interesting. And I know I sound like a jerk.
I fine. I sound like a jerk. I don't care. I That's a question
that needs to be answered. And she's in politics now. If she
wanted to be a widow, then, you know, she should have just started
some
and said, "We're giving out the Charlie Kirk Memorial Scholarship
or something." But she took control of a $500 million
allimportant political org that just got way more important.
And, you know, succeeding a guy that died, it's a little it's
a little suspicious. So
yeah, I I
gave me a very bad taste in my mouth when I I Am I the only one?
I mean, tell me what you think. One's in the chat if you think
I'm on to something. Two, if you think I'm a Cuz I'm actually
>> Let's run this. >> I'm actually curious how many
people bought it. >> Go ahead with the numbers. >> And
I didn't want to say that right out of the gate cuz I know how
that sounds and I know that comes across a certain
>> but I'm just telling you gut level my reaction when
I >> Hell of a lot of threes in the chat. That's very weird.
>> I saw her first speech. When I saw her second speech,
I said, "I don't like this. Something's not right here.
This is weird."
Her first speech in the Charlie Kirk studio, I said, "This something's
off here." She comes out and given a speech and she's like, you
know, she's not even crying. Like, we know what she's not even
crying. And it's once again, this is not like we're interrogating
her. Why aren't you the uh the cries of this when you say your
own cry will echo around the world or your own tears will echo
around the world like a battlecry whatever the she said when
you say it about yourself when someone else says it it's like
kind of okay when you say it's like dude that's
weird that was weird you crying it's like isn't that strange
this is like other people were crying I was almost crying you're
his wife
>> stop the cap I don't have the soundboard but stop the
cap >> he said Almost. He said almost. >> I was almost
cry. No, you weren't. Yeah, he was almost crying. Tears of like
joy.
>> Like that's how he was. >> If you're his dad wife,
you're not
And she was pretending to, though. She wasn't crying, but she
was pretending
She's like patting her eyes. It's like, "Honey, you're not crying.
We know what crying looks like." Like, "Honey, you're not crying.
You're not crying." >> It would have been sweetie. No.
If she got up there and she was like beside herself, disheveled,
maybe someone was helping her, maybe she couldn't finish it,
maybe she was actually crying. I'd say, "I needed this [__]
to look like a mess to buy this. Okay, you looked well put together.
You looked like you haven't cried in days." >> Bless your
heart. But she came up there and she's like giving this scripted
speech, doing this whisper thing. I was like, "Yeah, no,
sorry.
Sounds fake." And then she's
>> gay and cells are like woman whisperers. I trust him
when he says he wasn't actually crying. She wasn't actually crying.
H >> giving another speech a week later doing the pose.
The pose sent me. It's like oh
>> She was literally doing Shawn Michaels. Remember when
Shawn Michaels fought the Undertaker at Wrestlemania 25
and he came out in all white and Undertaker came out in all black.
It was like that. She she literally
Okay, this guy I'm just gonna be real with you guys. I've never
been more certain in my entire life that he has writers for his
show that they write the show because I don't believe for a single
second this ever watch wrestling. I don't believe it. That's
like the first wrestling reference I've ever seen from him. I
do not believe he's ever watched wrestling at all. And he's saying
it's like this. Get the out of here, dude. It goes out there
and she's like this and the fireworks are blowing off and she
says, "I forgive the killer." Scripted and now she's in charge
of Turning Point. I I think that's very suspicious. So, I think
you're right to question it. I think that's an arranged marriage
if I've ever seen one. But that's just maybe I'm an
I think that's a question that needs to be answered. >> Brett
Cooper sent $20. >> Brett Cooper. Okay.
is um >> Hold on. We're going to harass. It's >> going
to ruin your day. >> One second. One second.
>> Please give a warm welcome to Mrs. Erica >> This
is going to be the place. >> I think I'm cute.
I know. I'm
I've got the look
that drives
wild. I've got >> What is this song?
>> I watch wrestling.
Okay, you're
these references. Yes. >> Oh my. Okay. Okay.
>> I'm not your boy.
>> I'm just a sex boy. I'm not your boy
I make them hot.
I make them chill.
Their knees get weak.
Whenever I'm around, they see me walk.
>> That's it for that. Okay, there we go.
>> Isn't this Shawn Michaels song? Yeah. Nick just said
that he thought she was like Shawn Michaels coming out in all
white and it was a it was a reference. You get it if you're paying
attention. Plant dad. Come on, man. >> Come on, man. >> It's
very gay. >> Uh, yes. No, no, no. It's like uh it's different.
Actual gay dudes. Okay. Actual like gay dudes who groom themselves.
No, wrestling is gay in like a deeply closeted you try to be
masculine. It's like that kind of gay. It's like a different
kind of gay. All right. It's a way different kind of gay. All
right.
Somebody linked me this post and I'm not totally sure why this
is a relevant thing. I'm going to look at it. I forget who linked
me this giggling smiling. Oh, it's just somebody who's pointing
out how weird she was with Trump, I think. Oh, apparently giving
the middle what? Whenever the people need a hero, we shall supply
him. Albert Pike. Oh, this person's this person's referencing
Albert Pike. Do you guys know who else references Albert Pike
all the time?
>> I know this one. This is uh I actually bought this book
because I was like, I wonder if there's anything like funny or
interesting in it. I bought a copy of the book cuz Zurka was
shilling morals and dogma by Albert Pike as one of the Freemasons.
He's like, you need to this is how you will understand like like
actual magic. Okay. And I was like, oh, I wonder if there's anything
interesting here. It was one is the most boring [__]
I'd ever read. Returned it. I was like, "Oh, maybe it'd be interesting
when Audible would let you return books like after listening
to the whole thing." Yeah. Confirmed Zionist. Okay, that's not
that's not interesting. >> Wait, read it.
>> read it. >> If you are not yet a member of the
P. >> Okay, hold on. What did it say? She's of Swedish
descent from her father's side and Syrian, Lebanese, and Italian
descent from her mother's side. She comes from a Zionist family
with ties to Israel. Her organization with Romanian orphans has
been accused of child trafficking to Israel, UK, etc. The evangelical
ministry was contracted with the US military. It seems like she
was in the club already before they planned to put her in power
of TP USA. >> Oh, this has some they thing in it. Never
mind. >> So, I also got linked uh what is this? A documentary
on Erica Kirk. Okay.
>> 18 minutes DD got a podcast.
>> Please just watch my like two-minute video about the
trap door.
>> Two-minute video about the trap. lifting the veil in
the trapoor.
But this guy has a channel. This guy has a channel where he literally
just analyzes every Charlie Kirk conspiracy theory without sound.
Okay. This is the channel that gave David Pacman his capability
to debunk the what was it? Range day bro video in his video.
So people are pushing out the trap door theory to make the real
information
Oh Charlie Kirk analysis a deliberate
The so-called truth community could find this information was
immediately false. As you can see, the underground access trap
doors were to the right of the tent, not underneath it. Oh,
the Bushman theory is still best. Dude, the Bushman theory was
embarrassing.
>> which one's the Bushman? >> It's the one where
he looks at the four pixel bush and goes, "This is clearly a
human being right here. This is clearly a human skin tone. This
is clearly a >> Mhm. I see the human in there. >> That
dude is out of his mind.
Hold on, though, cuz we need to look at the shape of this. I
could have sworn based on where the trap doors were that they
were in the middle of this thing in the in the photo. Maybe not.
Hold on. Why don't you show me? I see trap doors there. But can
I get Do I need to look for the actual trap door theory video
that we had? [__] me. Hold on.
Uh cuz I saw where they were. Am I crazy? Oh, no. Maybe not.
>> Did they think it was some magician? Uh, Jtock does.
Jck thinks this magic trick. >> Okay, now hold on. Hold
on. >> Charlie just slipped through. >> No, these
are the two trap doors. These are the two trap doors. >> Charlie
went through the trap door and he's chilling on an island with
Tupac right now. That's what Jay's dog thinks. >> I wish.
Anyway,
the the they did they cemented like over this stuff the next
day or something. They put new paving stones down. I'm guessing
they aren't even cementing over it. Somebody said Somebody said
cement, but it looks like they're just putting new paving stones
down. I'm guessing cuz the previous paving stones were like caked
with blood.
>> That is You can't power wash that. People can power
wash like 10 years of smut and grime buildup
on the pavement. >> Smut and grime. >> I don't know.
I don't know. Those are the two dirtiest words I can think of.
>> Smut and grime buildup. Power washing. Okay. All right.
>> What does smut mean? I I think she heard power watching.
>> No. Okay. All right. Uh let's see here. Exposing Charlie
Kirk's widow, Erica Kirk. She's not who you think.
All right. So, awesome based conspiracy
>> Link is in the description. Please consider becoming
a >> the Martin Luther King Jr. Hidden Agenda. Hero or
hoax? Antichrist?
What? Bro, what?
>> As you will have access to many videos you cannot find
here on YouTube. >> Video will drastically change your
perspective surrounding this entire situation. I highly encourage
you watch it until the end. Okay. >> Oh my god. Reuben
says they need to get rid of DNA so people won't find out that
it was a double. >> So just ina just in case they don't
clean everything up, that's why they want to pave over it. I'm
seeing that.
>> Okay. videos where you're either going to gain a lot
of subscribers or you're going to lose a lot of subscribers.
And I guess we're going to find out together by the end of this
video what the outcome will look like for me. Um, we spent quite
a bit of time talking about Mr. Charlie Kirk, but we spent very
little time talking about the person who is now. >> Okay.
Not in appearance, not in voice, not in anything. Somehow like
>> you're going to say something racist. This guy reminds
me of STV Philly.
>> I knew you were gonna say something. >> It's like,
but it's like it's like I think just somehow in like the feel
of the channel. You ever seen if you've ever seen STV Philly's
>> This is literally his >> channel with his like
black culture. Uh >> I knew you were going to say. This
is his YouTube channel. >> He doesn't hide his face. He
just doesn't go he doesn't associate with the STV Philly. This
is his YouTube channel.
there. No, but he's got a different YouTube channel that I'm
>> No, I'm just lying. I'm straight. I'm >> Ah, you
son of a [__] >> Straight to your face. >> Yeah,
you actually you I didn't believe you. I didn't believe her at
all. I didn't believe her at all, but I was like I was signaling
over to her and she was like nodding to me
>> lying. Oh, that's the CEO of his company, Turning Point
USA, Miss Erica Kirk. And I must tell you, it's very early where
I am, but I couldn't wait to record this video because I found
some very interesting information about Erica Kirk. And I can
almost guarantee you by the end of this video, you will find
out several things about Erica Kirk that you will not only find
interesting, but I guarantee you that you've never heard before.
Some of this stuff you've probably heard. A lot of it I can guarantee
you you have not. And it's videos like this. >> This day,
this video is 3 days old. I've definitely heard some of the stuff
in here. further support
that a lot of these people in my opinion are placed in front
of them. I think that they're regular everyday people come from
good families, work hard to get to where they are, but these
people are playing roles in my opinion. And yes, we've already
covered the fact that she was wearing a Freemason ring during
her video where she was supposedly
>> Okay, never mind. Never mind. This is going a little
deeper than I've been. All right, I did not know she's wearing
a Freemason's ring. You are allegedly >> Wait, that was
definitely in the the Oh, that was in the tweet I had up for
sure. Hold on. >> This is his casket, right? >> Wait,
wait, wait. Yeah, that's apparently his hands. What do you remember?
You were telling me about the uh It was you, right? They was
telling me about coroner reacts or whatever. >> Yeah, the
coroner reacts. The >> corner is reacting to >> inbalming
to the inbalming. Why >> process? And why is >> Why
does Charlie Kirk's skin look like this? Inbalmer reacts.
>> they react for everything on YouTube. >> Rubbing
the hands of Charlie Kirk in a casket, which I do not believe
that that was Charlie Kirk. Yes, we've already discussed her
very odd and unusual behavior during her tribute video and also
during the memorial service. I found her behavior to be very
odd, which by the way, that that's not what I wanted. I wanted
to go to her video and I wanted to see a woman that was grieving
and I was going to feel really bad and I hated that she had to
go through this, but I went to the video and and and that's not
what I found. It was very odd. I'm not going to ignore my intuition
and my human instincts and everything's telling me that that
woman is acting. And it turns out that I'm not the only person
that believes that.
>> Very strange. Isn't it weird how all of us feel like
this is really weird? It's like weird squared. It's like really
weird how all of us feel like this is really weird. >> No,
but he's spitting >> as many other women and mothers who
and widows and not only that, but white widows. If you all for
those of you who want to say that there's a cultural disconnect,
there are many other white widows that also have watched this
>> He said the white women are agreeing with us, ma'am.
This is not a cultural thing. The white women have said you are
not human.
>> Well, little does you realize that this is just like
true crime. White women love true crime and this is just like
true crime. They they would love this no matter what. Okay, >> they've
seen this a million times. The husband dies, the wife did it.
Mhm. >> I don't care if they caught the
I know the wave did it. >> Video that I have later found
out that all feel the same thing. Her behavior was odd. But I
digress. We've already discussed Donald Trump's odd behavior.
Not just on the White House lawn when he was asked about how
he was doing less than 2 days after Charlie Kirk was supposedly
taken out. And he said that not only is he doing very well, but
he immediately deflected to some ballroom that they're building
on the White House campus. Not to mention Donald Trump dancing
and celebrating on stage at the memorial as if this isn't once
again a memorial. But I digress. We're not gonna talk about any
of that. I have a lot of new information for you because
>> that was so funny. By the way, when he dances here >> on
stage at the memorial as if this isn't once again a memorial,
but I digress. We're not going to talk about any of that. I have
a lot of new information for you because we've also already covered
that Erica Kirk uh won the 2012 MissUSA pageant uh which was
owned by Trump which by the way in my the evil truth behind the
modeling >> wait she won MissUSA. She won one >> Yes,
she was Miss Arizona and she won
>> Oh, crazy >> industry on Patreon that I dropped
several several weeks ago. We actually discussed what actually
happens to many models as many models was interviewed a decade
ago and they exposed a lot of the people that assaulted them
and what it actually takes to become a top model and to actually
win and how Donald Trump >> No, she won Miss Arizona USA
in 2012. >> I knew she won Miss Arizona. >> We also
covered you said it so confidently. I just wanted to trust him.
Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein actually worked in this industry
together both overseeing and hand selecting themselves many of
the women that modeled. I want you to keep that in mind for later
in this video. But I do want to share that Erica Kirk actually
shared on a podcast one time that she not only never competed
or participated in any pageantss before, but she also never done
any modeling at any point in her life until one random day she
received an invitation in the mail to start doing it. So, the
story is something that takes many women years and years and
years to perfect and to
>> Have you ever seen America's Next Top
like MissUSA is a little different
and
I don't know, man. >> Beauty pageantss are different uh
cuz it's like it's multiple things in one, but you can if you've
ever seen Miss
right? You can turn a dog into a beauty pageant
winner.
>> With just some like hard grooming. >> I think
like it's just I'm sorry. It's genetics. It's how pretty she
is, right? Like there's personality things there, too, but there's
no reason that like doing pageantss growing up would make you
better. I I feel like that could be learned pretty quickly or
you could have a natural aptitude for it. I don't think that's
that crazy. >> Also, being a model is not hard. What are
we talking about? >> Also, isn't her family like rich and
Like bribing a Miss Arizona USA, MissUSA Arizona judge can't
be that expensive, >> It's quite literally genetics. Do
are you tall? Do you have good proportions? Do you have good
fat to muscle ratio?
>> Nice smile. >> Brain says she's not even that
pretty. She is mid. >> I mean, by definition, she is not
mid. She literally won >> Miss USA Arizona. Okay. I don't
know. >> Gorgeous. You might just not be attracted to white
women or something.
uh or >> Erica Kirk was able to join and win MissUSA or
Miss Arizona within a year or two in the business. Now, once
again, in that Patreon video that I dropped a few weeks ago,
many of the models talk about how there's only about 1 to 2%
of >> Oh, he's showing his dude. He's showing his own work.
That's >> all models, regardless of what they are, regardless
of how good they are, that actually wins because it's more than
just your performance that gets you there. But I digress because
it gets weirder. Erica Kirk was also a casting director at the
same exact time that she was modeling. Now, it's not clear if
she was a casting director for Trump or not, but at the same
time that all this was happening, she also owned a ministry that
partnered with the US military in Romania. And in the same area
where they were working, the locals were accusing many evangelical
ministries of kidnapping children. Now, that doesn't mean that
Erica Kirk did this. I'm not accusing her of orchestrating these
things or being behind this, but it is responsible for me to
state that during the same time at the same area that she was
her ministry was working many >> I love how like actually
just like propagating conspiracies is basically like
being passed off as the responsible thing to do now. It's like,
listen, I would be remiss if I didn't point out that there were
accusations against some adjacent agencies and organizations
that were kind of operating in the same area around the same
time. It's like, well, wait, did she have anything to do with
it? No, I just feel like I have to mention it. Why? I
listen, it's a conspiracy. Get on board, man. >> Of them
were being accused of kidnapping and trafficking children. And
yes, the responsible thing to say is many locals could be lying.
That's true. But these children were being sent to Israel, the
UK, and other unknown islands. I also want to state that Erica
Kirk also visited the Pentagon in 2012 while she was modeling.
And >> so I've been able to travel to the Pentagon. I've
been able to meet General Salazar, who's actually out here in
Arizona. And I've also been able to donate a Johnny's locker
to the soldier nurse center, which you're looking at right now.
So, there's been a lot of things that have been going on from
working in the military to traveling to just being able to get
out. >> Well, here's another good one for you. Did any
of you know that before any of this, any of the pageantss, any
of the modeling, uh Erica Kirk, before she was Erica Kirk, was
actually an actress on television. Here's a clip from >> Oh,
also
the crazier thing. All right. The crazier thing to me was
that the US attorney that Trump put in Virginia to indict James
Comey to allow like the the grand jury to be formed to indict
James Comey was in the same pageant as Erica Kirk. >> Bravo's
real >> Oh, wait. >> That's That's the craziest one
to me. >> Damn. Also,
this is the funniest model meme. You have to pull it up. >> This
is This is how hard it is to be a model. It's a Tik Tok.
Hey, hold on.
>> Have you ever seen these?
>> This is like high fashion
I am perfection.
I like my Louis
be my reflection.
I'm proud of what you got. Now I'm missing attention.
You want to be like me?
>> You know, it take your whole life to be a model.
>> so like basically you just need to fall backwards. You
just need to like trust fall into the air and they get the picture
at the right time.
>> it's just so real. >> I don't get any of those
jokes cuz I don't know any ads for any of the but I assume for
a lot of people that was good. I feel >> How do you find
like this? Usually when Jay- Sock is talking, I'm on my phone
looking at stuff like this. >> Show Summerhouse.
>> Hold on. Actually, I need to back this up just >> an
actress on television. >> Oh, that she was an actress.
Erica Kirk was an actress on television. >> Here's a clip
from Bravo's reality show,
>> Wait, she was an act. She was on reality TV. That's
not being an actress. >> That's not being so conservative.
Way more conservative than Charlie Kirk.
>> It's not. It's also not. >> That does fall in
line with maybe having a [__] stamp.
Oh, >> a little bit. Yeah, you've missed like 12ish bads.
Well, that's what happens. >> Thank god. >> As bad
as bad as bad. There's at least
>> I'm not doing >> Well, how about this? Did you
all know that Erica Kirk's mom not only worked closely with the
government, but specifically with Homeland Security and the Department
of Defense? >> Can I ask a question? This might be off
topic. No, I didn't. How did your mom choose Phoenix? So, she
chose to move to Phoenix uh from Ohio because there was more
of a um an opportunity for a female business owner out here.
Um especially from the standpoint of she was getting involved
with u the government. So, Homeland Security and Department of
Defense. And so, she had other business partners that were out
here that were already in that industry. >> In fact, do
you even know who Erica Kirk's parents are altogether? It says
here, "Erica Kirk's parents are Kim and Melanie France or France
V." Kent France V was a prominent figure in the defense industry.
Oh, this guy's the chair of chairman of Rathon's Israel division.
Did Erica Kirk's father build the Iron >> Why do I know
what Rathon is? Why have I heard that before? >> Military
contractor.
>> Yeah.
Like uh engineer like missiles. I think they're one of the biggest
manufacturers of missiles specifically.
>> Okay. So, at this point, it's safe to say that she was
uh trafficking
>> I uh I don't know about that, but I Oh, wait. Hold on.
I I actually didn't even He literally says including the Iron
Dome. having chaired Rathon's Israel division and been involved
in significant military projects including the Iron Dome. Melain
France v's background is less publicly detailed, but the family
has been noted for their connections to conservative and pro-Israel
circles. Erica's upbringing in this environment, combined with
her own public roles, has placed her at the center of discussions
regarding influence and alleged covert operations.
Now, would you look at that? So, that means not only was her
family
>> I'm like almost nervous to ask what is the Iron Dome?
>> Um,
it's the
anti- rocket defense system that protects Israel from the rocket
strikes from home. So, basically fires a rocket, it immediately
does like a ballistic trajectory on it, shoots it out of the
sky. >> So, there is a dome there or >> it's a figurative
dome. It is a Is it like a dome? like a radius radius >> basically
around Israel around a lot of the populated cities of Israel
where like this will take out rockets that you're not >> someone
said STV is spitten
>> currently her family is very well connected but they're
connected to
>> he he has the same accent like this guy's from like
Philadelphia or something right I feel like it's the same accent
feel like I hear the same >> I feel like I can hear the
same accents as I can with Philly >> a black accent >> no
or her currently her family is very well connected but they're
>> very well connected very well connected >> that's
more southern Philly is not
>> uh connected to Israel the same foreign nation that
many Americans are not rocking with right now including myself
and I guess that could further explain Charlie Kurt's undeniable
record over the years when it comes to Israel I don't think >> that
sounds like he's from Virginia
>> yeah Baltimore close one of those two people ever thought
that it was just strictly about the Bible. But this also means
that Erica Kirk uh was successful and a millionaire well before
she met Charlie Kirk because of all these ventures that she was
>> I don't know you guys know this but there are there
are some rumors going around that are totally fake totally obviously
not true but she has quite a prolific jaw okay in terms of its
Not as much in terms of how far it juts out but in terms of its
broadness. And
listen, I've seen a couple posts now about her being male to
female
female friends
>> women have that jaw.
>> Nemo in the chat so proud. I started this one. I started
iron jaw. Okay, >> Hey, Erica Kirk. >> Wait, wait,
wait. Erica Kirk's father. Okay,
his greatest invention. First he made the iron dome to protect
Israel. Then he made the iron jaw to save Israel. Okay,
that jaw will be used
>> to spread propaganda to protect the >> Because
of all these ventures that she was placed into before she met
him and now she is
>> uh not pausing for that. Why was she in
>> Why the is she in a Hello? I
this I've never heard this part of her backstory at all that
she was in like the army or something. interest that she was
placed into before she met him. And now she is the CEO of Turning
Point USA. >> What's this? >> Uh, this would be MissUSA.
>> Oh, right, right. >> Right. Trump International
Hotels Las >> It's probably the bikini portion of >> Oh,
wait. The A is for Arizona. Okay. I thought she had like an Amazon
logo. >> No, the A would be a watermarking for whoever
took the photo.
>> it wouldn't be Arizona. But let's continue. Did you
know that she is actually currently considered the most powerful
woman in the country? And many are suggesting that she should
run for vice president in 2028 alongside JD Vance as >> they're
gaslighting her. Nobody is voting for that ticket. >> Yeah,
I don't >> that heavy eyeliner ticket. Get the [__]
out of here. >> I don't think that works, man. >> Looks
like she had her Miss USA sash on in the photo. Probably some
sort of out outing involving that. Ow. >> Many view Charlie
Kirk as a future presidential candidate himself. And it also
doesn't help when there are emails going out from Turning Point
USA where Erica is stating that she will quote unquote carry
Charlie's torch. But we'll see. Let's talk about Erica and Charlie's
first date. Apparently, it was for a job interview only after
a close a quote unquote close friend recommended that Charlie
should hire her as they were celebrating a new Turning Point
USA location. This was back in 2018, which is only 2 years after
Charlie and Trump started working together on Trump's campaign.
Remember, at this time, Erica Kirk had already been working under
Trump in the modeling industry. So, it would make the most sense
to me that either Trump or someone close to Trump recommended
Erica
>> I mean, I could see that. I could see that being like
a thing. It sounds like her parents are connected. those burgers
and eat right near this very table was the first time dad I met
mama
and it started as a job interview and I was asking all these
questions asking all these questions philosophy
Jesus
and then I realized mama was beautiful and smart and elegant
and Christlike and so I said forget this job interview
I want to date I said I have enough friends >> this is
like I'm sorry. Your kid doesn't care about this story. Your
kid doesn't understand possibly the story at all. This is just
a Tik Tok. That child is a prop for a Tik Tok right here.
>> I It's like not even a short story. This guy's straight
up monologuing to his >> I want to date you.
And I said, I have enough friends
and that's where your journey started. And I've already covered
the weird story of the 72-year-old man that supposedly started
Turning Point USA with an 18-year-old Charlie Kirk after convincing
him not to go to college, but I digress. Anyways, Erica has man,
>> that's where your journey started. >> And I've
already covered the weird story of the 72-year-old man that supposedly
started Turning Point USA with an 18-year-old Charlie Kirk after
>> we we need to go back and watch him cover that story
then. Do we
you think it's a JLP type deal? Do we know do we know what this
guy thought about? >> I don't know if it's a JLP type deal,
stop your stop your school path and go down this road.
>> Yeah, certainly interesting. Montgomery
>> convincing him not to go to college. But I digress.
Anyways, Erica has also shared the story of seeing Charlie in
Israel. So, there's the Israel plug once again. and noticed that
he looked familiar but was too afraid to approach him. And then
they were run into each other again in America supposedly. And
if I haven't blown your mind yet, keep listening. Did you know
that Charlie Kirk's family was closely and heavily tied to Donald
Trump as well as his parents worked really, really closely in
the Trump Tower? It says here, late Turning Point USA founder
Charlie Kirk's parents were longtime Trump allies. Charlie Kirk's
parents worked with Donald Trump long before the presidency.
Unlike their extraordinarily famous son, Charlie's parents did
not spend a lot of time in the spotlight. Not >> they didn't
hate Donald Trump. >> Much is known about his mother, Kimberly
and Kirk. But we do know that Charlie's father was Robert Kirk.
And Robert had a pretty strong connection with Trump long before
his son did. It's unclear exactly how Charlie and Trump became
acquainted, but it's likely that it was through his father and
the work he once did for the Trump Organization. Kimberly's career
and her affiliations are mostly unknown. While Robert was a businessman
who worked as a project architect manager on Trump Tower in New
York City. Now, would you look at that? Would you look at that?
Once again, as I always say, it's the weird connections. How
many people do you know are able to create a multi-million
well over hund00 million yearly annual budget organization?
>> I'm sorry. Why would a project manager be
communicating with Donald Trump? >> Architect. I mean,
>> that's not a director. That's not an
>> there wouldn't there this is stretching to me. That's
that's a reach. >> I mean, it probably was already stretching.
I'm sure Trump's got tons of employees. I unless there is like
a So he says they were close reported. >> Hello guy is
a CEO. >> Can we Can we see Can we see where that information
comes from that he's saying? Cuz like what he said he said like
reportedly they were close. Oh, I guess it's just this one. >> No,
he's saying that they had connections to Trump. And so the connection
is the father was a project >> Did work for the trumpet.
Oh, yeah. But it doesn't even say it's Yeah, I don't see anything
about them being close >> on Trump Tower in New York. >> He
says so, but the article doesn't say. >> Now, would you
look at that? Would you look at that? Once again, as I always
say, it's the weird connections. How many people do you know
are able to create a multi-million well over a hundred million
yearly annual budget organization by the time they're 25 years
old. Not saying that it's impossible, not saying it's never been
done before, but but you have to be connected to the right people.
You have to be selected to do these type of things in this world.
What we were taught as children how you can do and you can make
it and you can become whatever you want. It's a lot of stuff
that was left out like privilege, like connections, like being
a part of these secret organizations and societies. But not only
that,
>> um, somebody did want to point this out to me.
>> Listen, I'm not
It's just weird. It's just like a weird thing. Okay. >> It's
like a little weird thing. >> What's weird? What else is
weird to me? >> Somebody left a comment. Somebody left
a comment on Erdate's video. Okay. With JLP.
Great interview. Not so Erdate is very reasonable. Glad Jesse
is still around. Now that sounds like a totally normal comment
to me until you realize
>> that comment is from her husband. It's just like like
offhand as if he doesn't know who he's talking. It's just weird,
>> Wait, this interview is under Natto Aid's video or JLP?
>> No, this will be JLP's video. I just seemed odd that
he would leave a com like it's just weird. I don't know. I just
thought it was funny. Somebody linked it to me. I thought it
was kind of funny. I don't know why you got to be doing [__]
like this. >> Do you guys need money?
>> I don't know. I don't know what they need, man. What
do the reply say? I got no idea.
>> I don't understand what's there. He's already exposed
for being like a predator. Why are they Did they just Did they
just find out? >> What's that? Did they just find out that
JLP was like a predator? >> Oh, and they're trying to get
out on the >> They're collecting them all. >> Yeah,
sure. Could be. Yeah, >> JLP does fit in with that whole
coalition. Yeah, >> did a J. >> They just got tacked.
Now JLP, >> let's go. >> University, which is Regis
University located in Denver, Colorado. And her grandfather is
a guy by the name of Carl
>> Hold on. I I also just realized there's a lot of overlap
between Teone and JLP, right? I think there's a lot of overlap
between those two people on Andy. Yeah. Metaphysical level. Yeah.
The extremely closeted energy they both bring.
Like Teone describes making out with his friend in like vivid
detail. Then he's like, "But don't worry guys, it's not gay cuz
I I the girl later, explains no details of that, but it describes
his the bristles of his like beard and mustache rubbing up against
his friends. It's like, okay, are you him and JLP would have
a lot of fun wrestling, I
Oh my goodness. >> Located in Denver, Colorado and her
grandfather that there's a guy by the name of Carl Kenneth Frvie
who was the vice president of American Banking Note Corporation
which is the same one tied to secure printing and IDs and was
by the king of Sweden. But we go a little bit deeper. Meanwhile,
Charlie Kirk's Turnpoint USA UK. >> Technically, her grandfather
was a Viking. And what did Cash Patel say when Charlie Kirk passed
away?
We'll see you in Valhalla, brother.
>> Launched at the Royal Automobile Club under Prince Michael
of Kent, Grandmaster of Freemasonry.
George Farmer, who is Candace Owens's husband, set as chair.
>> Oh, this connection actually does make my brain wrinkle
a little bit. Ah, that's [__] up. >> Ah, that's
[__] up. Cuz she if she was wearing like a Freemason's
ring or something that that makes my conspiracy brain wrinkle
really hard. Okay. See? Oh, and then the Candace Owens >> Turning
Point USA UK launched at the >> It's almost certainly nothing.
I'm just Listen, I try to control that part of my brain sometimes.
>> Royal Automobile Club under Prince Michael of Kent,
Grandmaster of Freemasonry.
George Farmer, who was Candace Owens's husband, sat as chairman,
tied to Andrew Tate long before Candace. So, it begs to differ,
begs the question, is Erica Kirk a CIA MSAD plant cosplaying
as a trad wife that was hand selected to be Charlie Kirk's wife?
One could even argue similar to how Melania was hand selected
for Mr. Donald Trump himself. But I'm >> like out of a
catalog or >> none. The biggest red flag in my opinion,
whether you all agree with me or not, is Erica Kirk and Charlie
Kirk's children. Now, I noticed this before, but it's really
stood out to me since. >> This is going to be unhinged,
isn't it? This is going to be like
Erica Kirk needed a Swedish Viking Freemason husband. And so,
Charlie Kirk has to let these jeans get past. Anybody anywhere
on any platform, Google, Instagram, YouTube interviews, can anybody
find a solid photo of what Erica and Charlie Kirk's children
looks like? Yep.
>> Uh, wait, is this guy not understanding they probably
try to protect their faces from being on social media?
No way. Right. >> Right. because that matters because you
have some people who who are going as far to say that they believe
that this Erica Kirk and this Charlie Kirk relationship was completely
arranged and that they probably weren't together like the public
thought that they were. Many much like how a lot of celebrity
relationships are arranged to make power couples to bring in
more fans more attention a better dynamic because whenever you
have a spouse it just looks better sort of how that works in
the indust in the music industry or in Hollywood. What makes
it any different here? I went to Erica Kurt's Instagram and just
about everywhere I went to look. It's very difficult. >> This
is This is such a self-report. It's a little goofy. This is a
gig of self-report on this guy that he wouldn't know that. That
you wouldn't know that like social media people literally hide
their kids intentionally because they don't want their kids'
faces shown. They don't want them tracked like their whole time
growing up. They don't want them >> You know what? You
know what this is like? This is like going to an influencer social
media page that does of but you go to their Instagram and he's
like there's something off here. Do you notice how every photo
her feet are blurred always? What is she hiding behind the blur?
>> What actually do her feet look like? >> Does she
have webbed toes? Is she a >> What the >> What could
it be? >> What could it be?
not only of their children, whether they're in interviews, whether
they're out to eat, whether they're at the zoo, whether they're
walking in the park, they always have their children's face hidden.
But it's also very difficult to find any pictures of Erica Kirk
pregnant. Even though it's it's easy to fake pregnancies, it
was very difficult to find that. Now, for those of you who want
to be devil's advocate, and you're going to say, "Well, I mean,
a lot of parents do that, right?" Right? Like I know for a fact
uh JCole, the rapper JCole, it's very difficult to find his children
anywhere on the internet as well, right? But I think you can
find one or two photos of what they look like. It's because he
wants to keep his children out of the spotlight. He don't want
to ever use He's talked about this in his music um over the years.
He does not want his children to be used to gain attention or
sympathy or more fans. He wants people to like him for his music
or dislike him for his music. He don't want to use his family
for that reason. Are you all going to make that same argument
for a person like Charlie Kirk and Erica Kirk who encourage people
to get married, have children, build a legacy? You're going to
not show what your children look like. And it's very very orchestrated
and every video and photo they go out their way to >> maybe
the kids are Romanian.
>> Make sure that their children's faces is completely
turned. They'll cut the video short before their child's face
is >> This part is really stupid. That's weird. Yeah. >> Now,
for those of you want to say, "What's your point? What are you
getting at?" Well, I don't I don't fully know what I'm getting
at outside of the fact that once again, there are many more red
flags when it comes to >> Listen, man. I don't even know
what I'm cooking here. I just I got questions. >> The situation
things aren't adding up and there's a certain um picture that's
being painted here and and the more and more we investigate,
it's becoming more and more obvious to me that these people that
are placed in front of us are not who we think. Even though we
want we want to believe that so badly, they're just not. Right?
So, at the very least, that's what I'm stating. Right? Will I
go as far to say that this relationship was arranged? I'm open
to believing that. I'm also open to believing that this assassination
may have not been an assassination. Right? I'm not going to full
out come on and just say that as of yet, but I'll include the
video that's convinced me. >> What does he think? It it
might not have been an assassination. Was it a like what else
could it have been? >> I
I don't understand the purpose of suiciding like this. It would
make
no sense. What else could it be other than
>> I don't >> that Charlie Kirk may have even been
in on it. I'll include that version on Patreon because of course
five years reasons. I can't include that on YouTube. But I will
say this, I'll make it free for everybody to watch. You don't
have to pay. You just have to become a free member. Um, man.
So, I will include that on Patreon and you do not have to pay
a dime to watch it. But yeah, and I want to state this again.
I I made a post yesterday. Um, yes, I'm skeptical of Ca Candace
Owens like many of you are because she has incredible reach and
you can't get reach like that as we've seen unless you're controlled,
right? The Catholicism piece, I don't understand it. It's cringe.
It's like I'm with Candace 99% of the things that she talks about
and then she she starts talking about Catholic Catholicism. I'm
like, Candace, stop. Stop. Like I start twitching. I'm like,
I don't get it. The you have a team. The level of research and
you're talking about this Mary stuff. Like, it's odd to me. It's
odd. So, I'm not saying that Candace Owens is one of us, but
I >> Play the clip. You can't say that.
Can't say that. >> I literally have it up because somebody
linked me the uh somebody linked me the tweet earlier, but it's
just to say, look at her eyes. She had some freak in her. I can
see it. Which is a fair reaction to this clip if you haven't
seen it yet. >> You don't get to ask those questions.
What's wrong with you, Mom? Why you so scared? You don't get
You don't get to ask those questions.
to ask those
What's wrong with you?
>> I don't I don't know what's going on here. Okay. This
is like
>> I'm scared because you just did that. >> K-hole
yammerings right here. Yeah, it's very weird weird stuff.